good morning millennials
come back to the toast happy Thursday oh
my God it's the latter half of the week
and we are continuing friends and family
week here at the toast with a highly
requested very special guest it is Tick
Tock girly realistic what are you
realistic haul creator
influencer I don't know Remy Vader hello
thank you for that what's your sorry I
totally bought you what is your Like
official bio what is your official title
I never know what Creator and curved
model
yeah I knew I [__] it up content
creator and Curve Model Remy Bader is
here hi Remy hi thank you for having me
thank you for coming back it's been
almost a whole year since your last
um appearance on the show I think I came
last year right after Coachella oh my
God so that's actually what I wanted to
talk to you about we're going to catch
up and stuff before we get into all the
stories and we both watched a new
episode of Vanderpump Rules last night
but I was thinking about you this week
because this weekend is Coachella and
you're not going why not I just like
really wasn't sure if it was for me
so last year was your first year yeah
um and now that you're a year out from
it I think the last time we spoke it was
a little fresh a little raw for you yeah
now you've had a whole year to process
what that Journey was like tell people
who've never been to Coachella why it
wasn't for you and I've been twice and I
totally understood all of your concerns
realize you've been yes of course it's
not for me okay yeah well after I want
to know why it's not for you but for me
personally I just felt like I can't say
it's like a a bad place to be like it's
a wonderful place if you're into that I
realized after that I'm a concert girlie
not a festival girlie that's fair I love
to be a controver I know every word and
I'm there for that person but like why
would I run around in a desert hot field
that takes an hour to get into
sweating dripping you know once you get
in there you're not even getting out for
a few hours because it's like a thing to
get out all day all day
I'm like trying even I just feel like
honestly it was my sorry you're fine it
was my personal experience that
everything went wrong and that's why I
can't be like you I would never say to
anyone like you don't go to Coachella
right but if you are someone like me
that I don't know if there's many people
like me that have those exact
experiences but like the sweater you
have triggers triggers I'm triggered by
heat 100 that was a huge problem I had
when I went to Coachella but for me the
reason why I disliked coachella's I get
was uncomfortable and like I was sweaty
and like there was a lot of long lines
and walking which oh my God I'd be
walking and walking in the heat where I
was like trying to wear like I was also
like trying to like be cute that was
crazy in that weather a hundred percent
I could get past that I really could but
at the end of the day like I'm measuring
life experiences in the amount of fun
that I'm having right and I didn't find
it to be all that fun especially as like
a influencer podcast or content creator
you go to create content so it's very
much like a work it's like a conference
and every there's so many different
brand events and and everyone's just
like competing yeah to go to the best
events and you ended up like oh I think
I'll go to this party tonight you always
end up choosing the wrong party like
it's just I don't know I don't find it
that fun I'm more of a stagecoach girl
no Brands go to Stagecoach it's very
chill I love country music the same
please yes the same exact Festival the
week after Coachella weekend number two
see I'm surprised that you go to that
then I love the music it's way less
Fanfare there's not like famous people
there it's just like people who like
country music and it's so fun it's like
really the best country oh yeah because
Coachella is known for it's just so
hyped up but it's not even it's also
years ago like I remember in high school
being like I'll never go to this it
wasn't something I looked at I was like
this is so cool like when everyone was
wearing the hats and doing the Instagram
pictures I'm like I hate that oh no I
saw it and I was like dear God please
one day let me be cool no I really
really really I need to go to synagogue
every Saturday if you just let me be
cool and wear hats like that with beads
on my face God I will eat kosher please
yeah no not me but the one thing is I
feel like everyone was like oh my God
she clearly had a horrible time to like
revolve Fest or something because all
that drama happened last year I actually
like have a little bit of fomo because I
had the best time specifically at
revolve fast yeah because I went with
them so I'm not I don't know I can't say
like how everyone else's experience was
that just like went I know like [__]
went down but for me I have me and Nikki
my sister had a wonderful time yeah and
like we're that was where I had the most
fun because it was more of a VIP
experience it wasn't as big as Coachella
no matter if you were GA or VIP I like
really listened to the artist and had
fun and it was just that was more up my
alley yes I will say the last time I
went to Coachella Jackie and I also went
to a revolve festival and it was
probably better than the
um the thing is with the festival
it's so much work to get there like the
flights and the outfits and you get
there and you walk and you walk and you
walk and you walk and you walk and then
you finally get there and I will say
like I under I understand why people are
obsessed with it it's so beautiful did
you have an artist pass yes I didn't
yeah okay so for people that don't know
like if there's VIP and there's GA but
then there's an artist pass which I
wasn't cool enough to know about and
people like oh you have artists by us
and I'm like no no people are so
annoying about like what type of tickets
yeah that's what I mean too and I'm like
no so then some of these influencers are
so goddamn annoying you have artists
pass shut up [__] okay shut up that's
what I mean with like the competition
that's what I'm saying like mind your
own goddamn business [__] and go put
your fishnet stockings on and eat my
[__] ass with a spoon that [__]
bothers me I agree that's what I'm
saying so when I was just like in the
VIP and I realized I thought VIP would
be close like for me I like to connect
to the artist so I like to be as close
as possible you're more of like an indie
music no other girl like I go to the
front and I'm like yeah I know you're
like locking eyes like the lead singer
no I actually I know what you're saying
when I go to concerts I I don't wear
glasses but I could benefit from wearing
glasses and I bring a pair of glasses
because I really want to see the artist
then I feel like they can see me like
when I go to Broadway shows when I saw
funny girl I was literally wearing my
glasses I really want to see that by the
way oh my God I know but I what were you
talking about Coachella artist pass yes
I didn't do that and then I realized VIP
I was a million miles away I was like
how is this VIP and I just like that was
what it was everything you're saying and
like the pictures and everyone like
one-upping each other I just started
looking or there's a video of that not
the video of me like crying there's a
video of me just like standing around
and like looking at people and being
like what Jesus and started laughing
because I'm like this is just a joke
it's like a Content it's a Content
conference it's like VidCon almost yeah
I've never been there but I know what
you mean me neither but I'm assuming
that's what goes down yeah
um so you're not going to Coachella this
weekend what are you doing
well I'll be in the air conditioning in
my apartment smiling
um no actually smiling
just like staring up at your ceiling fan
yeah I don't know actually I really oh
so like next week is my sister's
Bachelor I party in Tulum I've been
hearing a lot about it so I'm really
preparing it on the week after three
days in between and then I'm going on a
brand trip to Turks and Caicos I know
all about it still be there really yeah
I didn't know that so I like need to
just like chill calm down but I might
like maybe like go out once like maybe
if you want to get a drink or something
I'll be here I would love to get hibachi
or something
Hibachi let's get her back because I
just heard you like what did you think
about you posted on my Instagram Story
the history of by the way do you know
Steve Aoki is the heir to the Hibachi I
just posted on my story I go this is
crazy I know there's actually um a
picture of him when you walk in and you
know if you go to the there's one
Benihana in the city and if you go there
you're like 95 likely to see Tracy
Morgan he's always there that's so
interesting both times I've been there
in like the last five years I had my
like 25th birthday of Benihana no I
think that's cool it was so cool that's
the coolest and the thing is all you
need is like 10 people to get your own
table and you have to pay for like a
room rental you get your own room it's
kind of like a low back I did all of my
so I at the corner of my street when I
grew up I had a Hibachi place at the
corner of my street so I was like yo
it's all me for Hibachi and and I'd be
like let's go Saturday night and I would
like throw parties and I forget you
don't have to rent it yeah just like the
huge table I was like 20 of my friends
and I was like this is the coolest thing
I've ever done you know what that
reminds me of last night on Vanderpump
Rules they were like kind of making fun
of sheena's rehearsal dinner the girls
who weren't invited I'm like that
literally looks like the best wait I was
gonna say that whole thing looked really
fun it's kind of changing my mind a
little bit because I was very much like
not saying I'm getting married anytime
soon but I recently spoke to my
boyfriend I go I just want to let you
know because I have sweating issues and
all this stuff like we will not be
getting married anytime like anywhere
outside no I used to say that when I was
getting married I wanted to have a
winter wonderland yeah wedding in
December outside
that's interesting it's snowing perfect
yes so like I just and he was like maybe
um well like maybe like a way in one no
I know there too I know so I'm like
already having all these rules just
thinking about how I'll be anyways but
like I watched my point as I saw the
wedding and I was like it's not one day
like you have all these celebrations
around and like it just was it looked
really fun I know she actually did a
really good job and I was really I don't
want to get too much into it because
we're gonna have a whole segment at the
end but I was really impressed with
Sheena like the whole episode my
takeaway was like Wow sheena's kind of
like a mature Queen okay well that's I
just was talking about this in my chat
with my mom and my sister last night
because I love your mom by the way yeah
she's funny she's a queen well she was
like love Sheena and I was like honestly
like I don't agree with you like I was
like I think she's like a little
dramatic I agree with how she was during
the wedding like I thought she'd be
bugging when yeah I'm like whispering
and um
and then I was like and then my sister
was like yeah Mom what like she's
dramatic and we were like fighting about
who we liked and who we didn't like and
stuff but I do think that she handled
herself very well especially for like
that for me like I like have no idea
what I'll be like when I'm a bride but
I'll probably be like a little bit of a
scary that was gonna be my next question
like what kind of bride do you think
you're gonna be I was and I'm just
speaking from experience the most
miserable [__] you've ever met and I
never use that word
you've ever met in your life like so
control and hate if she heard you use
that one I know but you know what
sometimes it's the only right word I'm
sorry Mrs Bader sometimes it's only
because
I have respect for my elders I say Mrs
she hates it I I like grew up and that
was like what I was forced to do and I
felt like so awkward and now it's just
just so you know like every time I go
like still to the safe like my guy
friends walk up to or something and
they're like Mrs Mary she goes it's
Adina and don't you ever call me but
she's so sexy
um I just was like the worst type of
bride so I relate to where are you you
were constantly stressed so stressed I
like refused to offload any of the
planning to the actual wedding planners
but I had like you know I had this like
big deal with the nod and our wedding
was going to be in the magazine and I
was just like so it became like a work
thing which I hated and that would be
like my biggest piece of advice
or like a content creator who is going
to be like posting their wedding it can
become work and it work equals not fun
no matter what you do right so that's my
only piece of advice it's funny because
Nikki is being who I thought who I think
all be and I'm shocked is she being a
brother because she's more not
bridezilla like but I've never seen her
more anxious and bugging about
everything weddings are perfectionist
wild and like just being like even she
hasn't slept in days and she's like I
don't know why and she's like being
crazy and I'm like we chill like we're
good and like it's easier said than done
I know and if I had I'm just saying if I
had me as a maid of honor like I know
I'm like are you the maid of honor yeah
who else would it be yeah I just want to
say I don't feel like you kind of convey
um any sort of calm energy like right I
understand why she's stressed you are
quite literally her maid of oh yes but
I'm but like I am like Queen Planner
yeah that's like I like have always
hosted parties for people I'm like love
hosting planning making things perfect
so like even though I'll bug until the
moment like for my parties and stuff
like I've never had a bad party I've
never felt like I've like [__] I dropped
the ball on this like I always plan
things accordingly yeah and for me I'm
actually being extra chill because I'm
like she'll just bring up like the
bridal party when this is coming up and
I'm like let's not focus on that that's
in June one thing at a time this is like
coming up in a week like and we're all
good for it so like let's just live in
the moment I'm being like a hippie man
yes
you know the first time you were on this
show this is not your third time correct
yeah and I remember exactly what I wore
in every feeling about the last time
that I don't remember anything when was
the first time you were a guest first
with Jackie and I okay then you
co-hosted yes you I actually remember
you wore a black body suit and blue
jeans I was like oh my God and I don't
remember that and that was the most like
nervous day of my life and then we sat
here for like an hour afterwards talking
[__] about every single person yes
because that's like all I ever dreamed
of doing with you guys and I was like
this is the closet but so the first time
you were here you would like just popped
off like your life was changing you were
in this like very transition I think you
were really overwhelmed I mean I don't
want you to get mad I mean I want to
talk about this but like I have to
adjust myself like I feel like I was
sitting like this the whole time lean
back I don't know what to do okay hold
on
see now I could like see you and sit I
want you to be happy remelina Okay go
again so the first time you were here
your life had kind of changed overnight
through Tick Tock you had blown up and I
think you were feeling like a little
overwhelmed by the whole and now it's
been how long have you been two and a
half years does it feel more normal now
because your life just changed on a dime
I still feel like it was yesterday yeah
I really do because I'm like I it like
scares me in that way because I'm like
all right I'll get to the Halls next
week and then I'm like realizing I it's
been a tuna like I just feel like I'm
having I'm still having a hard time of
like focusing on myself and like right
now I'm in myself period of like your
reviews yes like and I'm really like
focusing on myself and all it's good but
then I like push away the content and
then it stresses me out that I can't
give that to my followers I do a bad job
of doing both and giving it to myself
and to everyone else and that's how am I
still trying to manage that two and a
half years later that's what's in it
it's not that long like this is a very
abnormal
um like way of living right and I think
it's so important I actually spoke about
this a lot in my book like doing the
toast gave my life so much structure
because yeah being a content creator
like your life is pretty structureless
you know you work at all hours of the
day and then no hours of the day you
have weeks that are so busy you can't
breathe in weeks where like kind of
nothing's going on you're like I could
literally get a day job right
um and so doing this every day kind of
give like a 95 structure to my day and I
feel like a lot of the most successful
content creators have like such crazy
structure in their their day just to
avoid that kind of
awkward yeah I need that yeah and I
almost feel like just even me this is
the first time in my life not my life
what the first time in years that I'm
even getting up earlier again because I
used to be an early bird like I would
even get up in college at 5am to study I
would never study at night I'm going to
be at Starbucks at 5am when it opened so
like I like missed that version of
myself and I'm bringing that back and
even just like getting up earlier and
doing these things I'm like wow this is
like a little of routine this is
structure this is what I've been missing
since before covid so I'm getting there
yeah and then I think I could in a way
like I'm feel like I'm working on so
many different things that but for the
first time I realized this the other day
too like everything the first year was
just like public and on Tick Tock and
whatever the second year was all of the
things I was working on like coming to
life and I had announcement announcement
announcement it was like wow this is so
exciting and now for the first time it's
like I don't have these announcements
but I'm working on so much that I can't
even like talk about and that would will
probably come about like next year like
am I not doing enough no that's that's
the thing about like this line of work
is you're always looking at what other
people are doing and comparing like oh
my God yeah of course that's just human
but I've talked to you you've helped me
a lot with this I always tell my mom
that I'm like Claudia helps me a lot
because I'll be I'll like you know I
very open about when I feel a certain
way and I'm like oh my God like am I not
doing enough or I feel like I'm focusing
on too much like and you're like you're
going to have periods in this like job
where it's what lies and lows highs and
lows everybody you know wants to work
with you and then there's a few weeks
where it's like you're kind of
irrelevant and it comes in waves and as
long as you get comfortable knowing that
there are going to be highs there are
going to be lows there are going to be
months that are you know you're bringing
in more money than other months and
other months where you're just like kind
of slow like it's okay actually lean
into those slow moments because then
there are months where you can't catch
your breath and you long for for a slow
month right and that's what I'm trying
to be okay with right now because it's
not even I have to understand like it's
not even slower like this is like good
for me but I couldn't even handle what
was happening before because that was
abnormal and now I'm like oh it's like
it is some weeks are busier some weeks
are not but when those weeks are busier
I'm like I can't breathe I need a rest
so I'm like I just need to like lean
into it more and I think that's what I'm
doing now I'm like I'm having a little
bit more time on my hands where I'm like
great I can actually go to the gym I
could do some nice things for myself and
I cooked the other night for the first
time in two years I saw your steak and
pasta yeah I feel like gratitude is so
important not to sound literally like a
freak but being grateful when you're
busy but also being grateful when you're
not like you need to be grateful for the
opportunities that come your way because
like everyone no matter who you are like
you work hard to earn things in this
life and when you get them you should be
really grateful for them and then then
it's just also about your perspective so
like when things are going you know slow
you can think like oh my God like nobody
wants to work with me I didn't ever like
I'm done in this business or you could
think like wow I can take care of myself
I can reset I can relax so that when
those months come where I'm like really
busy I can lean in yeah and give it a
hundred percent like here today at the
toast you're gonna give it 100 you
already know I'm excited I'm happy to be
your end I do you feel the difference of
like the last time I was here which is
just funny because I feel like the first
time I was here I was a fan the second
time I was here we were friends but like
now I feel like we're actually friends
where I feel comfortable where I was
like we're friends but I'm like still
nervous and bugging you still had your
wall up yeah I'm not nervous now oh good
I mean we share a physical therapist we
share a lot yeah we both went to
physical therapy yesterday Frank who do
you think Frank likes better
it was kind of like a really good
patient like I make my appointments I
show up every time I do my exercise at
home like I don't know how Frank
couldn't like me and I'm hilarious on
the table
well I just want to say to everyone that
like Claudia didn't find Frank I found
Frank I never said I found Frank people
I never yeah oh are you going to
Claudia's PT and I was like I'm
triggered you want to know why they said
that because I'm consistent and I always
go and whenever I go I post to support
local business this is the first
yesterday was the first time I went into
in a year and a half I'm just consistent
and I never said I invented Frank I
actually said I got him for Margo who
got him from Remy right and I never said
I invented talking you up so okay yeah
he was just like I got like 20 new
patients the other day when she posted
support local business yes so then I
started being like oh [__] like I have
to post and he's kind of like like
turning us against one another
great wait also was just funny because I
like didn't I was so tired when I went
yesterday and just like out of it
because I've been working oh yes I was
like I'm sorry Frank I keep yawning and
like whatever and he starts like
whipping out the camera and I'm like
wait I mean you know my hair is
everywhere I'm of no makeup and I texted
Claudia after and I'm like I had no idea
I was going to a photo shoot at PT yeah
he was he was like yeah well Claudia you
know let's read the videos and do this
and I was never gonna say no to Frank
like yeah I was like yeah dude and I was
thinking and he's like can we take a
picture together and I'm like ah like I
wanted so bad to be like could we just
do this next time but I didn't have it
in my heart to do so yeah well I always
go to Frank after the toast so I always
look cute and the first time we took a
picture together and I was like oh I
should look cute every time in case like
he wants to take more photos with me
well you know what I was thinking oh my
God I just cut you off no it's okay I'm
just always making content at PT because
you sit there for a while with that
machine on your back so I'm like
taking pictures of myself okay well I'm
sorry that I'm in pain so am I that's
why I'm at PTA [__]
like I literally like saw you on your
phone I'm like oh I could be on my phone
like when I used to go I would like
literally put the phone aside and be
like because I was just like so serious
and it wasn't a fun thing for me but I
did enjoy it more yesterday I just said
to Frank I said I feel more motivated
than ever like I want to feel better I
just don't want to be in pain that's how
I felt I'm like my back hurts like after
long days and I'm going to take
the matter into my own hands right like
last night when I got home like can you
believe I was actually doing some of the
things you told me to do did you do your
exercises yeah I was like pulling like
pushing myself up in the bed and
um
oh I post oh I actually yeah I remember
yell at me I get a no I get a little bit
of like an older Tanner version of like
Ben vibes from him yeah that's a
compliment I'm gonna tell Ben which
because you did well I got in trouble
you said he was like oh cute oh my God
yes I did say we can cut that out we got
it but then I started looking at him and
I'm like I get it because this is like
Ben like I get why you see that yeah no
that's fair we could cut this out
because now
no he does because let me tell you
because I had said I was sharing
listen and you cut things out on here I
can but I'm not because this is funny
because I said on the first time I went
I told the story about how I
accidentally took my pants off when I
wasn't supposed to and the whole
situation was like made even more
humiliating because he was like a
handsome guy and that clip went so viral
and the next time I was like there's no
way Frank saw this clip where I called
him handsome he's like my wife saw it
and sent it to me I'm like oh my God now
him and his wife and I was like so
mortified so you just called him
handsome and now I feel better that I'm
not the only one and I'm not cutting it
out
okay so having said that let's dive into
a little bit of Pop Culture news the
fast five stories that uh you need to
know today's episode is brought to you
by State Farm the State Farm personal
price plan helps you create a plan that
gives you options so you get an
affordable price and it comes with a lot
of benefits like the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and an affordable price just for
you you know Jax and I my queen Jax
we're always talking about how important
personalization is and how personal some
things can be Insurance of course being
one of them poetry another comedy
another food another you know some of us
are folklore girls and some of us are
Evermore girls and that's because it's
personal
personalization means you have the power
to choose what you want to include and
what you want to leave out it it just
feels better that way and why shouldn't
insurance work like that too that's what
the State Farm personal price plan is
all about you can choose to include
options like bundling your home and auto
policies and that means you'll get the
coverage you want at an affordable price
just for you in the end you have a
policy that gives you what you want I
mean T Jackson I have you met two girls
more similar but even our insurance it's
so personal that we have different needs
you know Jackie's a homeowner Jackie has
two cars you know
some of us are just blessed like that
it feels better and State Farm knows
that like a good neighbor State Farm is
there oh I'm sorry like a good neighbor
State Farm is there
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability
availability and eligibility may vary
thank you State Farm for sponsoring
today's episode of the toast
all right first up we've got some news
that I feel like you're gonna have a lot
to say about okay did you see this
Ariana Grande thing yes she posted this
video
um she was addressing body shaming
comments so Ariana Grande is getting
candid about her health the pop star
took to tick tock on Tuesday because she
was inspired by Remy Bader to shed light
on her mental health addressing recent
comments about her body in a rare
three-minute confessional this is what
she said I don't do this often I don't
like it I'm not good at it but I just
wanted to address your concerns about my
body and talk a little bit about what it
means to be a person with a body and to
be seen and to be paid such close
attention to there are many different
ways to look healthy and beautiful and
personally for me the body that you've
been comparing my current body to was
the unhealthiest version of my body she
continued I was on a lot of
antidepressants and I was drinking on
them and I was eating poorly and I was
at the lowest point in my life when I
looked the way that you consider my
health you consider healthy but that in
fact wasn't healthy she said healthy can
look different the second thing is you
never know what someone is going through
so even if you're coming from a loving
place or a Caring Place that person
probably is working on it or has a
support system that they're working on
it with you never know so be gentle with
each other and be gentle with yourselves
sending you guys a lot of love and I
think you're beautiful no matter what
you're going through no matter your
weight no matter how you'd like to do
your makeup these days
um thoughts Remy as like the the girl
who never asked to be the spokesperson
of body
positivity neutrality but who is
I'm gonna get [__] for that she is not
the spokesperson you get [__] for like
whatever yes and honestly you should
yeah I don't really care anymore so
um yeah I saw that I reposted it I truly
believe I just I I don't agree with any
sort of commenting on anyone's body like
I just like especially if there is a
public figure because I'm like they are
people think that you're not people she
is reading that maybe not every single
comment but she sees it especially if
that's like the majority of what people
are saying and you really have no idea
what she's going through clearly if she
feels obligated which she never makes
videos like that I know come on and say
that like something's going on and she
wants to make a point the fact that she
was saying that it was unhealthy for her
and whatever it's just like why do you
have to dig and when I reposted that
video I was getting messages and it's
funny because lately when I get I'm
saying I don't care and I do in the way
that I'm like I actually respond more to
people like shut up now like I'm like ah
I I'm sorry like I I don't care like
I'll block you I said like just go I
mean I've always been a blocker but like
people were messaging me no but she
really needs to figure out her body and
I would respond and be like I'm sorry
that's very rude and you shouldn't say
that yeah like even if you're saying it
to me I don't care I'm not going to
agree with you like why why do you think
this is a just a genuine question do you
think that people feel more comfortable
um commenting on the body of a thin
person
yeah I feel like people
they probably the people that maybe
wouldn't comment on someone like my body
because they think that they're doing a
good job by not doing that but they're
like an ally but they're like right but
then they're like oh well she looks
unhealthy in the other way right I can
comment on that and that's absolutely
not true so okay this is my question for
you because I feel a certain way about
it and I don't know if a lot of people
agree with me do you think it's the same
thing to comment on a curvy person's
body and a thin person's body
like is one of them worse than the other
I think I always grew up feeling like if
you comment that someone's fat or on a
curvier person's body that it's worse
and I do think that there are
I do think deep deep down I think it's
worse deep deep down but I've learned to
accept more and understand and
understand more what you know people
might be going through with that they
can't gain weight and things like that
where I used to get pissed like most of
my friends from college are
I mean all of my friends from college
and my group of friends are skinny like
it just I didn't choose that people
think I choose skinny right it is how it
is and I remember one of my friends
always complaining being like I can't
gain weight and it's so hard for me and
I'd be like oh shut up I know and now I
really like have seen some of the things
she's gone through and I like actually I
think I like a year ago apologized oh
wow for maybe some of the like me just
making it a joke years prior because I'm
like no like I don't know like you you
really have no idea like what is going
on and I I yeah no I agree with you
something I struggle with and I'm not
saying that I think my version of
anything is right it's like I have
always felt like it's not the same to be
told you're too fat and you're too
skinny right because we live in a
culture where
skinny is a good thing it's a currency
it's like so calling someone too skinny
is like calling someone too good it's
like it's we put a positive connotation
it's getting in a negative one on fat so
it's like to be told you're too fat it's
like you're too negative and to be told
you're too skinny it's like you're too
bad too but then I also I see the flip
side it's like well shut the [__] up
about whatever anyone's body looks like
yeah I just I definitely and it's
something I don't have like clear
thoughts on but it's something I don't
really fully understand maybe that's
because I've literally never in my life
been told that I'm too skinny me neither
and I've never I can't even relate to
the sentiment of not being able to gain
weight but I know that that's a thing
for people and I totally respect it it's
so foreign to me I I have no idea what
that's like like if you've ever been in
a really bad place do you choose to eat
or not to eat that's an easy question
but no without question to eat right
I've never been so heartbroken over
anything that I lost my appetite
I found a newer deeper recess of my
appetite to dig into any time and still
to this day because I'm still struggling
with that if someone says something that
pisses me off or it's just something
more negative I go to food that is my
comfort so same I've never dealt with
the opposite but think about putting
yourself in let's say her shoes and I
have no idea what Ariana's going through
and her being in such a maybe deep dark
place that she's truly can't eat I am
sure that that's a traumatizing thing
too yeah so I understand both sides but
I do also with what you're saying I I
like how you explained it too because I
think it's just being fat no matter what
is still negative yeah and in in the
mind of most people in the world yes and
it just it is a dig when people question
yeah you posted something yesterday oh
my God I knew you were gonna why what
did I do
I wanted to ask you because I had never
heard of the phrase body checking
okay first of all it's crazy that you
saw that because it was up for 30
minutes
and Claudia you were the only person in
my head oh my god well because I mean
audio talk about this stuff a lot but I
was like literally in the back of my
head I'm like Claudia's gonna disagree
with this post by the way well so I only
first of all I didn't really I think I
disagreed with it but I don't know what
body checking is I hadn't hadn't heard
that phrase I didn't know before my
eating disorder treatment at all and
people were saying and I was like what's
body checking it's a good question yeah
so it's when you are
staring and looking at yourself in the
mirror and like looking at like your
body and whatever but you're doing that
then you're
body checking is just that really oh my
God I literally did that this morning
right but like it's a not it's something
that people are always a lot of people
are doing but what I was trying to say
is body checking bad it's it's bad why
because I don't want to say the wrong
thing but no because I'm trying to like
three we're just working through
thoughts everyone right right
um it's supposed to be yeah bad because
you're you're literally
you're staring at yourself and
constantly checking on like what you
should be looking like and looking it's
like weighing yourself constantly got it
but you're just looking at yourself in
the mirror and looking at your body and
like like constantly it's a it's a bad
thing I guess in the world of like
reading recovering got it okay okay and
what I was saying and I realized I
rarely ever in my two and a half years
delete videos that I post I'm like very
confident with what I post how many
times you watch a video before you post
it like you wait a couple hours I don't
post immediately I don't watch it
usually okay unless I feel like I [__]
something up I said yeah like not [__]
it up like where I'm like uh like I need
to cut that up because I like hesitated
or something but I really like I'm big
on my videos are better when I I do them
in the moment of what I'm feeling and I
want to get it out there this was
something I sat on for a week and I was
like okay I want to say it the right way
and to just explain what I was trying to
get out there versus what I realized it
sounded like and then started getting
automatically some negative comments I
was like this isn't worth me not
sleeping tonight and it's not what you
meant and it's not what I meant so what
I was trying to say aside from any
medications or what anyone's on because
I posted recently too I disagree I don't
think that we should be looking at
people's bodies and being like she's on
this she's on this I don't give a [__]
and like that's just not our business
yeah I agree what I am and what I was
trying to say which maybe you'll
understand more is that
I really I was on my Instagram the other
day and I just was scrolling through in
every story was people I know and people
I don't know of just
out of nowhere showing their abs out of
it's not showing a fitness journey or
whatever it is it's like all of a sudden
I'm seeing what I'm seeing it is is in
the behind it's like we're in this like
skinny era now I'm just gonna show I'm
really skinny now out of nowhere and
what's bothering me is that I'm not
saying because what people started
humping you're saying you people can't
show their progress over their product
that's not what I'm saying because I
guess I would want to do that too you
know that's where I started being like
Oh no that's not what I mean I just
think that people are leaning into this
like I'm seeing so much less of like be
yourself be okay with the videos that I
was making in the beginning of covet I'm
starting to see less of that and just so
much more like we need to you know go
back to being skinny and that's all
there is and it's scaring me so let me
tell you why I disagreed with it and I I
knew you would no I do and only because
it's like kind of a mentality I have
about everything in this life I feel
like what you're describing is a really
Niche trigger for you right and I think
a part of recovering from anything and I
don't know anything about eating
disorders so I might be wrong but I
think through like therapy and healing
whatever it is that you're triggered by
the point of of the healing journey is
to be able to be confronted by things
that trigger you because the the concept
that you know everything you see every
day is should should be a safe space for
you whatever that person is dealing with
whatever the trauma is is unrealistic
it's like friendly what's quote you know
to leave your house is to be offended
um so I what I felt was like it's almost
it's your POV right but it might not be
ubiquitous if that makes sense I get
that and maybe that's why I deleted it
because I feel like I'm good at feeling
like oh maybe this wasn't right and then
I wouldn't have deleted it yes and it's
just funny because I just didn't want
you to see it but oh my God I can't
believe you have this like complex about
me I'm crying because you know literally
I know what you think it's almost like a
Nikki thing like with my sister it's
like oh I know she's gonna cease I know
what she's gonna think and I don't want
to deal with the conversation so I'm
just gonna delete them no by the way I
totally relate to that like oh this is
going to get
um I feel like I used to be more in the
like I'm in a battle I feel like I used
to be more like I'm gonna battle this
and I'm standing for whatever and then
like lately I'm just like I don't wanna
I don't want to do it anyways I see what
you're saying and that is that is very
true I think it's a part of like things
when I'm like I go home and I'm in this
like
everyone put the food away in the house
and I realize I can't do that anymore
right I do I do
but I think it's more because it's a
public press thing right now that's like
what are they calling it not skinny girl
I couldn't even think of the word the
other day how people are saying like oh
heroin cheese heroin cheat yeah like
things like that like how it's like a
thing right now like a trend so I just
feel like people are I for the I thought
it was [__] the whole time and that
because I'm very much do what you want
it what makes you feel good we've talked
about this
but now that I'm starting to see it as
like oh my God I'm seeing what people
are talking about and it's in my face
and I'm not actually thinking about
myself because I'm okay and I'm not
getting too triggered where I'm not I'm
gonna go not go binge about it right but
I'm thinking about the people that are
following all these people that aren't
following them for a fitness reason or
because of their bodies and are
following them for their humor or other
things and are now going to be more
triggered than me and maybe don't know
how to handle that and I just am feeling
for those other people no that's a
totally fair
um mentality and I'm seeing it in the
eyes of like eating disorders which
again you're like okay not everyone's
dealing with that so I I see both sides
yeah I just delete it because I'm like
it's just not no I honestly feel like
the two things we're both saying are
like two major like conflicting schools
of thought in the culture right now
about a very serious toast I literally
but they are they're like two
conflicting schools of thought about
like a
um
well I had like a really good thought
that I can't remember what I was gonna
say but like essentially that like what
you're trying what I'm trying to say is
like you know we all are accountable for
like what we consume what we you can
unfollow what we allow ourselves to get
like taken away with like yes influence
is real but like if you are aware of
your own Consciousness and like you are
actively you know unfollowing things
like it's it's on it's on every
individual to protect their piece no one
is going to protect your piece for you
right and then I think there's another
school if that will say well why not why
can't we make a world where you know
everyone and everything is protected and
safe which I don't feel that way I don't
even write I feel more in like because
then the other side of Remy is always
like do whatever you want screw you if
you want to unfollow me you can unfollow
me I just think I'm just I just don't
want what I came on social media to do
to completely go away yeah no that's
fair that's totally fair yeah um all
right should we dive into the next story
because we did a major tangent but
wishing Ariana Grande the best you look
beautiful yes Caitlin Bristow has
revealed what she was paid for The
Bachelorette oh I didn't know that so
she was offered a measly forty thousand
dollars when she was getting to be The
Bachelorette in 2015. she went on the
trading Secrets podcast
um and said when she was on just the
bachelor as a contestant she was getting
fifteen hundred dollars
um between That season and then The
Bachelorette so she lived off of 1500
from ABC for the whole season no no
until just in that break period after
the bachelor okay before she was The
Bachelorette so they offered her forty
thousand dollars and she was like so
excited she was like I'll take it but
she had hired a lawyer and she actually
couldn't even afford the lawyer at the
time her stepdad had to had to lend her
5000 dollars and he negotiated way
harder and was like no forty thousand
dollars is not enough and put in all
these stipulations and one of the
executive producers called her was like
you got an entertainment lawyer and
you're asking for that amount of money
I'm sorry I thought this was about love
for you
and she was like [__] off it's about
love and money okay they go hand in hand
for me right now
um and she was competing against Brit
and so it was like even more complicated
in terms of the contract so she said she
wanted to make the same amount that
Chris Soules who was the previous
Bachelor made um which was arranged
between 75 and 100 Grand and she said
she was really smart with her
negotiations and she made sure ABC would
still pay her even if she lost the gig
to Brit because remember there was like
two bachelorettes at the same time
um she also negotiated that if it was
Bridge she got more she got the same
amount of money and then
um she also reveals the payment
structure for Dancing With the Stars so
everybody gets a sign on bonus for Like
Dancing with the Stars to announce like
these persons come in I feel like that's
really just based on your level of Fame
and relevance and then you get paid per
episode so that's why when people get
kicked off they're like bummed because
they stop getting paid okay and they
both obviously stopped dancing as well
yeah now my question for you is how much
would it take for you to be the
bachelorette because I think I would not
take a dollar under 20 million dollars
20 million I would not do it for any
less when you think about taxes and you
know
okay but like there's some people that
they're Dr like it's not my dream
because I'm also not trying to get
married that's my worst nightmare okay
well that exactly do you know how many
but there's some people that are like
I'll do it for five dollars do you know
how many scenes you have to film in a
bathing suit like I would literally well
that's why my like my dream in another
world would to be out in love Island and
I wouldn't really but I would rather be
I would need to be paid a hundred
million to actually do it because you
only stay in a bikini no and like
there's cameras in the bathroom I would
I think I would literally rather be
killed than be on love Island like that
sounds like my worst nightmare you meet
the parents and stuff in the bikinis
like it's crazy oh my God that's
horrifying yeah so there's just like a
real certain type of person who is built
for these shows like the bachelor in
love I was so die hard like I want to
get married now like I would do The
Bachelorette you would yeah but like
it's not happening I also have a
boyfriend you do have a boyfriend
congrats but like I
I can't think of anything more seriously
than being on a dating show like that
maybe I could be on Like Love is Blind
because there's not that much like
bathing suit content and it's right but
it's just crazy but like it's crazy I'm
realizing I think that's actually my
favorite concept of oh a show because
it's just so out of this world but the
fact that some people have worked out or
maybe like one or two couples in the
past whatever I'm like this is just a
crazy concept I agree I think the format
is probably I have a problem with them
though what because I do feel like I'm
like this is the perfect concept where
you actually could have some like
larger women and maybe some how do I say
this me and Ben went on a rant about
this yeah uh
more average looking people Everyone is
pretty average looking and they have
like diversity in a lot of different
ways but not in body diversity in every
dating job that's and that really poses
like an interesting
potential for conversations and
challenges and hurdles and and I don't
know why they don't do it it's very wild
I I guess like there was a plus size
curvy girl she like wasn't really unless
he's in but then they
she's smaller than me right and then
they they're I actually remember last
season there was like an actual
plus-sized girl and they like didn't put
they cut her out of the actual yeah I'm
sorry this is your chance on the perfect
show to truly have people that look like
all different type of actual people and
they aren't doing it and they're still
thinking it on that no and I think from
like an entertainment perspective I
don't know why they wouldn't do that I
do feel like it would make the entire
process more interesting and it brings
more viewers like I just don't get but
like that's a whole I just think that
there's so many I've been trying to
think I'm like what show because people
are like love Island like should have
you know more plus-sized people and like
we just literally said it as it is it's
like what if maybe some people are just
uncomfortable being a bikini all the
time or whatever it is this is the
perfect show yeah to have plus size
people on it and they don't do it that's
so true who are your favorites this
season on Love is Blind are you caught
up oh I'm so caught up it's like
everything I care about yeah
um
it's so easy to say my not favorites oh
go first Kwame yeah also I don't get out
you didn't understand I sent Claudia a
video the other day oh yeah of with no
context of like my boyfriend pretending
to be kwami and you're like what am I
looking at he was like walking around
the house talking on the phone I'm like
why are you sending me this video of
your boyfriend talking on the phone this
looks personal I'm like no like did you
get it to me by accident I literally got
in a fight and I just wanted to show you
what he was talking no like I literally
he was going or like whatever the laugh
was anyways I post on Tick Tock and
people understood oh good okay but um
I watched a six minute Tick Tock last
night of the com compiled of how much he
wants nothing to do with Chelsea I know
really was hard to watch I was going
like it was just hard to watch I feel
very bad for her but like she's truly
ignoring every sign but like maybe
that's just how she is I don't know or
maybe she just like wants to that's the
thing about the show it's like if you
are not into someone and you say your
true feelings you're cut from the show
so I don't think she's about the show
like seeing her sob and stuff she wants
to just get married I know she's so in
love with him and like he can't be
bothered I think he thinks she's so
[__] annoying yeah and he's
definitely one of the worst Zach I mean
there's just no words
okay I like was like in beginning I was
like justice for Zach and I do feel
because I'm sorry that girl was horrible
horrible but two things can be true he's
definitely odd oh my god bliss's father
hates him I know and bliss's dad is on
to something and honestly Bliss is
giving to something I thought he was
such an [__] like I get it I get it
Liz is giving such desperate energy like
she no I think she I think they actually
really like it that's what Jackie said
and Jackie said I actually think they
might are a good match but wait I think
they are she does she's not does not
seem annoyed by him like that's true and
like I would be for Jenny like stares in
her eyes and he's like enough but she
likes it he doesn't with his mom is I
like her a lot yes I liked her too
um and then this is I might get like
[__] for this but like oh what's your
name Micah yeah I don't think is as bad
as that other girl no I actually think
she's really into Paul same I don't have
a problem with her I think she was like
on a slippery slope to becoming a
villain but she cut off ties with Irina
pretty quickly like you're a mean girl
bye I don't think she I have no problem
with her I really don't know if you
really think about it because people are
like obviously I don't like how she was
like drunk and semi flirting flirting
honestly was more him out of his way
yeah that was weird no she was being
messy too but like yeah that's not a
crime but if you really think about it
she cut off Kwame in the beginning and
literally only wanted Paul this whole
time yeah like she has she's literally
only wanted Paul that there's kind of
like I just don't have a huge issue with
her but also her friends so freaking oh
my God that was really bad like who who
do you think is the hottest guy on the
show
we deserve anyone even oh
oh well he's like beautiful but not my
type I think Marshall's a very good
looking man like it's not like I would
go for Marshall yeah but like I truly
feel very sick for him and feel about
was it you that posted the other day
saying he's toxic or something no with
someone else that was like unpopular
opinion but like I think he's talking
I'm like I don't I think he's just like
a different kind of person than she is
they're not meant to be together I love
when people share unpopular opinions and
hot takes because I feel like everyone
pretty much like on social media says
the same thing regurgitated in different
ways of saying it yeah um but that's
just a horrible take horrible I actually
like I really just wish the best for
Marshall and I think that girl is a mean
girl yeah um but wait who do you think's
the best looking Paul
personality wise like I think he would
hate me and I would literally hate him
we would choke each other he's like so
like earthy and Greta tunberg and green
and Science and I'm just like give me a
plastic straw [__] I'm getting in this
Uber to go three blocks
um so like we would hate each other and
like on night one I'd probably strangle
him in his sleep if he didn't do it to
me first but physically I do think he is
the most good looking okay that's just
like a little bit about me okay
um so again how much would you how much
would it take seriously in this moment
in time for you to become The
Bachelorette
um
if I didn't have a boyfriend yeah of
course my God I'm married we're just
like three million okay I seriously I
wouldn't do it it would be like a
million it's not enough for me to
to be that don't expose you literally
like you're just like be you like being
the center of attention I do that's a
very good point
no I'm gonna take it as an insult I do
like to be the center of attention
um in this type of scenario where like
you're up for 24 hours filming Rose
ceremonies being in bikinis having to
like make out with people on TV really
they go on a lot of trips okay and they
get in a lot of hot tubs and they do a
lot of hikes like no
no hikes no like they don't have any
movie dates right no so what if you had
one dating show that you could be on
what would it be such a good question
okay what are the current dating shows
okay so Bachelor love Island
literally Never
Love is Blind Bachelor Bachelorette
Bachelor in Paradise no probably love is
blind love is blind and on the trip to
Mexico I just like pretend to get sick
or something is there anything else
right now I mean there's like a lot of
like bad dating shows right
um yeah love is mine's a safe one it's
safe I think but you would have to end
oh well you don't have a problem with
that no are you commit in phobic like
you don't want to get married no I do oh
okay I just I'm like I never thought
even to this day in my life like I
thought it would be probably like five
six seven more years till I have a
boyfriend that I'm very don't I don't
want to break out of my I just wanted to
be that person that was like career
focused for a while and like I and I'm
very content and happy I have a
boyfriend I love him but I don't want
him to pull me out of like I just wanted
together be like like working and have
fun and like whatever and I'm not saying
you don't do that but I just I think
[__] I'm fun like I'm literally there's
nobody more fun and you know what
there's I'm sorry but there's a lot of
my friends out there that got married or
engaged and turned boring okay but
that's a choice that's what I'm saying
like but it's rarer I'm so fun dude and
they're like I'm gonna just go sit in my
home I just feel like you are fun though
I have nothing to be afraid of when it
comes to marriage impacting the amount
of fun you have and the amount of work
you can accomplish that's all I'm saying
but live your life no I agree because
that I just think that it like turns
into like oh also because I'm very much
a person that loves to live alone so I'm
yes like I I just like I'm like that's
not happening anytime soon like it's
crazy to me when people are like oh are
you guys like living together and I'm
like we haven't even been dating a year
and that might be more normal for some
people but like for me no no and also
kids are so far down the line for me
that marriage just makes it feel like
that's closer but I know that you're not
like oh I'm gonna have kids tomorrow no
I think as long as you're like in
control of your life and making your own
choices like whatever you want whatever
you want all right next up Eva Mendes is
explaining why she and Ryan Gosling
don't appear on red carpets together
thus reminding everyone that these two
are together because I literally had
forgotten so in the comments on a recent
Instagram post in which Eva Mendes
shared photos from the 2012 Beyond the
Pines Premiere the first film she made
with Ryan Gosling she said she's only
comfortable posting images of the couple
that are already publicly available she
responded to someone saying what a cool
comment thank you the person had
expressed a desire for her and Ryan
Gosling to appear together to promote
the upcoming Barbie movie she said what
a cool comment thank you but we don't do
things like those together like these
photos I've been posting I'm only
comfortable posting because it's already
out there
they were only on the red carpet
together once because they were
promoting that film together between the
Pines I think it's called and it's so
true I mean they literally have two kids
together in 2020 I think it was or 2022
she had referred to him as her husband
on some uh Australian daytime talk show
and people didn't even know that they
had been married they are so secretive
there's literally two paparazzi photos
of them one from that Premiere and then
one when they went to Disneyland like
they're so low-key which obviously you
know makes me believe it's real you know
I think that it's literally what we just
said yeah it's like you have to choose
what you want to do and if that's some
sort of for we have no idea but for some
reason they made this decision early on
and they're just one of them really
wants to stick to that maybe like
I just find it I find it so you're like
no I just find it so unrelatable you
know like this
nope you have like a little thing I know
but you know my skin is peeling and my
because I got a sunburn and it's all in
my hair I just have to live with it okay
okay
um no I just I find it so unrelatable
because I can't imagine being Eva Mendes
with her husband as hot as Ryan Gosling
and being Ryan Gosling with a wife as
hot as Eva Mendes and not wanting to
like thirst out on social media because
that could quite literally never be me I
get a good picture of Ben I'm posting it
on five different things I'm uploading
it to Pinterest I'm literally on
flickr.com and Tumblr right but like
again this is how everyone's if like I
just said like I like to show off my
boyfriend but I refuse to tag him and
his let anyone know his name oh really
oh they don't ever say that in my life I
haven't said it no oh yeah so like
people are like why and I'm like because
that's what I decided because that's
your boundary so I just feel like
clearly it's something there's a reason
for it yeah I mean we're not gonna know
what that reason is no and I think the
reason is fairly obvious given their
level of Fame and how that can really be
so toxic I feel like I don't know I
don't know because he had that suit it's
funny because I actually forgot that
they were together too and then I
watched The Notebook with my boyfriend a
few months ago sobbing screaming and
when I watch a movie like that like I
get like very re-addicted and I have to
grab it to the whole Wikipedia and where
are the the great or the older versions
of them still alive which I don't think
they are one of them is and I just got
started crying again so then I started
looking to them and then I watched 15
times the video of Rachel McAdams and
him at the MDB kissing words running and
kissing like I'm addicted to that video
and I was like all I want is for them to
be together and then I'm like oh my God
he's with someone else and I started
getting upset I know but like so is she
she what she's with someone else too oh
yeah like they're both really happy I
know but like oh you know what that just
reminded me of when you were talking
about watching a movie Ben came into the
room the other day the will cackling at
your story about the whale
um we have both really been wanting to
watch it and we've sat down twice to
watch it and we've watched the trailer
and we we haven't even been able to
start it because I think I'm gonna find
it so [__] sad
it's there's nothing happy about it I
talked to Ben about this oh you did okay
guys yeah yeah
um he was just like do you think like or
whatever and I'm like there is just
there's a lot of controversy around it
so maybe watch it because you like that
like I want to see what what's the
controversy about that he's wearing a
fat suit no no no okay that
um no fat people were a part of making
this movie he's not fat the people who
made the movie aren't bad and that
they're just making it look like another
movie where it's like you are a
miserable person living in your home
eating your life away and hate your life
and end up dying because you're you are
fat can I say I actually do I don't
agree with the no fat people working on
the set like people gotta work you're
fat you're skinny you can do your job
I'm sorry I don't think that's a valid
critique but I do I I'm very conscious
of like The Stereotype in media of fat
people it's always like the lazy fat
slobby friend and I find it annoying and
or like the funny friend that never
hooks up with guys yes I find it
problematic I get that
but I do want to say that what Brandon
Frazier's character goes through you
know eats his way into Oblivion can't be
apparent that actually is a reality for
a lot of people so I don't know I don't
have a problem with it so all I'm gonna
say because we don't have to get deep
into it but like I and I still have yet
to again this was another thing on my
list those two things to make a video
about make a video and I actually don't
know how to say it the right way without
getting people pissed at me but I
watched that show I think God my
boyfriend didn't come over because he's
been asking to watch with me I said I
watched without you he was furious and I
said I wouldn't have been able to watch
this with you I cried the whole entire
time I was watching a worse version not
worse like a more extreme extreme
version of myself yeah I I couldn't
believe like there was just I'm not
giving anything away but there was one
part where he looked at basically like
I'm gonna die based on like he looked up
finally like what something about his
health and he was like it says like you
were gonna die basically and instead of
him doing something about it he ordered
10 boxes of pizzas and eight all of them
and I was like oh my God like this for
someone who is a binge eater this is the
reality of the worst situation of it not
getting better yeah and I think it's a
really real way to watch that and and I
don't necessarily think it was a it's
like inaccurate I thought it was really
interesting to watch I don't have a
problem with it at all based on what
you're describing sad if you don't want
to just be upset and watch a sad movie
like not ending well you're gonna like
then don't watch it and honestly I feel
like having that sort of depiction might
be helpful for people who don't really
understand that like being overweight
most of the time is not a choice that's
my thing it's a genetic pre it's
literally the number one cause of
obesity is your genes like you're
literally and so telling a fat person
like well don't just don't order pizza
it's not that part is a mental thing and
that's something and it's habit it's
like telling a depressed person just you
know you'll be fine get picture better
like and that's really my problem with a
lot of the discourse around these new
injection ozampic Manjaro these um shots
be because everyone's just like it's an
easy way out like it's just a really
kind of in my opinion like a really
uneducated way of
speaking about obesity you obviously
don't know anything about obesity
because I know for a lot of people these
injections have changed their lives
right and have like quieted a lot of the
noise in their head about food and it's
just the way that you know normal people
walking around can just like eat a meal
and move on with their day and not keep
thinking about it it's affording a lot
of people that luxury who don't who
haven't had that their whole lives we've
got a brand new sponsor today we are
very excited to be partnering up with
Lululemon to tell you all about their
new align collection you may have
noticed the pants I wear every single
day on the toast I got a lot of DMS
about them they are the Lululemon mini
high-rise Flair pant I love them I've
been in my kind of flare pant era kind
of evolving maturing and the Lululemon
align collection has been fabulous and
what's great about it is the flexibility
the four-way stretch means you can bend
stretch and move literally any way you
want to without restriction or
distraction I find a lot of times the
band at the top of like leggings or
flare pants will really hurt my stomach
and be like a belly ache throughout the
day not Lululemon this stretch this
comfortability is real it's made with
nulu fabric it's the softest comfiest
texture for your legs period the fit is
fabulous I mean look at me I look
stunning it shapes perfectly to your
body for a flattering look that's
Uniquely Yours and the best part is that
it's weightless that light weightless
Sensation that makes you feel like
you're wearing nothing and nothing else
I am loving these pants I can't lie I
have to wash them like every two days
because I've been wearing them pretty
much five days a week here at the toast
the entire line collection is really
really fabulous but I have to say the
high-rise mini flare pant is my favorite
and that's just because I'm in like my
flare era I'm like a flare girly get
into the Lululemon align collection at
lululemon.com that's
l-u-l-u-l-e-m-o-n.com and this
collection is the Align collection you
don't want to miss it today's episode is
sponsored by Dreamland baby we want to
introduce you to a product that over
half a million parents including Jax use
to help their baby sleep it's the
Dreamland baby weighted sleep sacks and
swaddles it all started with Tara who
couldn't get her baby to sleep she was
frustrated in searching for answers and
her solution was to create a gently
weighted sleep sack that your baby can
safely wear to help them feel calm fall
asleep faster and stay asleep longer
it's really genius it's the only sleep
sack that features cover com technology
it evenly distributes weight from the
baby's shoulders to toes and it
naturally reduces stress allowing your
little one to relax and sleep soundly
just like a weighted blanket can help
adults we all know that we love our
weighted blankets these gently weighted
sleep sacks will help your baby feel
calm much like a hug and your baby can
do anything in the sack that they can do
in a non-weighted sleep sack so if you
have a child who's having difficulty
falling asleep or even staying asleep
this is a safe effective product that
you need so it's the gently weighted
sleep sacks and swaddles they're for
newborns up to 36 months it's the only
sleep sack with that cup cover com
technology and it was created by a mom
so the gentle weight mimics the feeling
of a parent's touch or a hug we've had a
lot of success with the Bebes in our
family with these weighted sleep sacks
and as adults we know we've all used a
weighted blanket we know that it works
so your baby deserves the best the best
news is that they're offering an
exclusive discount to the toast
listeners just head to
dreamlandbabyco.com Pages slash toast
and use code toast at checkout to get 20
off and put your sleepless nights to
rest that's dream
landbabyco.com Pages slash toast a
little human interest news remelina
ready a five-foot man who struggled to
find a date has undergone extrus
excruciatingly painful 165
000 leg surgery that involved breaking
his bones so he could add another five
inches to his height
his name is Moses Gibson he's from
Minnesota and he had been insecure about
his height for years he first underwent
the knife in 2016 but recently had his
second procedure he is 41 years old and
he has now grown five inches and he is
saying he's feeling much more confident
what do you think about that uh I think
this is crazy but it's just kind of you
know like live your life if he's happy
and so confident I'm always uh I'm a big
proponent of like yeah this trend where
like we're all embracing our
insecurities that's great but like
sometimes you can't get past one one of
your insecurities and yes this is
Extreme and borderline kind of crazy but
you know what if you feel better I'm
happy for you it's the same thing about
everything like it's like I have never
I'm very much on like I just for me I've
never wanted to like
or something physically on me but I
literally feel zero annoyance or
frustration when other people do it have
you gotten any sort of cosmetic Botox
nothing the only thing I've ever gotten
for my TMJ was a little needle here and
it did not work oh you know what I was
gonna ask you I've really been having
bad TMJ and I've heard a lot of people
having success with botox I also hear it
makes your jaw like a little bit more
snatched it it does for me I don't think
I look any different than when I did it
but it also didn't work for me and also
you just have to be careful and make
sure you go to the right person it can
literally [__] up like your smile and
everything no that's not worth it it's
not worth it I think but also I
literally got a mouth guard in my TMJ
stuff like a really where'd you get a
mouth guard I will tell you the guy oh
thank you okay um but
yeah no I've I
for me I am oh now that's gonna sound
bad No One's Gonna say I'm proud that I
haven't but like for me that's the thing
for me like I was always like I'm like
you know what I don't want to I just
like whatever you know when people
choose to embrace yeah I get BOTOX
probably twice a year okay I can't even
tell thank you so much yeah I did many
years not many years ago probably 2018.
I got a natural neck lift which was
basically just like I got fat removed
it's not Buckle fat removal it's from my
double chin I would hate it this is just
a personal thing like I feel like people
shouldn't do the Buckle back remover
because I don't think they look good I
think no you know what it is it's like
it's a trend right now to have like
crazy ass sunken cheekbones and I don't
think in a few years it's going to be on
Trend because I do think it looks bad
it's kind of like how I feel about these
floofy eyebrows that everybody does like
they lick up their eyebrows all the way
to their [__] hairline and they look
nuts and the way we look back now at
like those really skinny eyebrows from
the 90s we're gonna look back at these
fluffy ass Groucho Marx eyebrows and be
like what the [__] were we thinking but
eyebrows are temporary I went home one
day with eyebrows like that and my whole
family said you look horrible no like
but that's it's a makeup Trend like you
it's fine you're not permanently
changing your eyebrows but the Buckle
fat removal I just I agree I don't think
it looks good and I think to permanently
do that I think a lot of people might
regret it they're gonna you have to be
so careful when you get caught up in
these beauty trends and I'm easily
caught up easily caught up in things and
so I try to be really level-headed about
it but you know I might in a few years
wish I had my double chin back I don't
think I will but I used to be very
anti-p like getting lips done like again
this is like how I actually I'm allowed
to change my mind of course like I used
to get like really mad at my sister when
she would get her lips done I'm like
you're gonna regret it you're gonna
regret it I have some friends that
actually look 10 times better like when
they had less lips and then now and then
what do you think about my lips they
look really good or they do you get them
done I have had lip filler maybe three
times in the last couple of years I get
it done
a very little amount once a year then I
think it's all about going to the right
person because like your lips
and again I just want everyone to like
look and feel their best but like for me
it's a choice I I've always had like
pretty decent sized lips and I'm like
I'll get in these phases where I'm like
should I and then I'm like nah no you
have nice lips there's no reason to get
something that you don't need just
because it's trendy
um so you're saying you would not spend
165 000 breaking your legs to grow five
inches nobody could do what he wants and
I'm not mad at him this is kind of like
white chicks where she says she got her
knees done and that's why she got taller
but it's really Marlon Wayans I don't
remember that but I saw that movie like
five times oh my God it's such a good
movie no I know well someone was like
you got taller she's like oh I got my
knees done they're like you can do that
I guess you can do you know what is
really crazy though when I when I was
signing looking into signing to modeling
agencies and I want to be a plus-sized
model I remember actually like this is
where I have like my little phase of
like zero confidence right before coven
and right before the videos I remember
laying in bed like crying being like I
just and calling my Dad saying I just
wish I was five and he said well Remy
like guess what there's nothing you
could do about that and I was like okay
I just gotta get over there he was wrong
yeah he was wrong
foreign
our fifth Story is going to lead us into
our little recap of the Vanderpump Rules
episode from last night but like Howie
Mandel is starting stuff have you seen
so I fell asleep last night to the
interview it was horrible which was
insane so Andy come on watch Happens
Live last night like kind of poked fun
at Howie Mandel was like just said you
know he stepped in [__] he didn't even
know what he was talking about he did no
research Lala went on her stories and
was like coming for him so now Howie
Mandel is slamming back at Andy Cohen
and Lala Kent after the controversial
interview so he caught Flack from Andy
Cohen and Lala and swarms of fans Howie
has clapped back he said I don't need to
do homework I know who Sandoval is I
know what show he's on it's very funny
to me now watching everybody else like I
don't even know some of the names of the
people that are in the show and I'm
getting hit hard for not knowing those
names he obviously he famously stopped
the interview and was like wait who's
Sheena wait I cried laughing Uber here
listening to you going shut up
she was annoying he's being so sorry
like an interviewer should know the
information thank you he reiterated that
he doesn't watch Bravo reality show but
he said he wanted to give Sandoval a
place where he can spew his side he
cheated on his girlfriend with her best
friend I still don't understand why it's
big international news though he doesn't
condone Sandoval's month-long affair
with Raquel Howie Mandel said he could
commend the bar owner quote for being
vulnerable and removing the stigma for
mental health people think they could
just say mental health and like
everything that comes out of their mouth
after that is right right that's like a
thing now where it's like well mental
health and it's like everyone's like oh
well mental health no you can't just say
that like that has meaning and what the
[__] is he talking about it really is
crazy and I do think that he chose I
guess he went on that like knowing that
he wasn't gonna get challenged yeah
that was the craziest thing and now I'm
watching last night's episode and all
the new episodes of inner pimp rules
with this lens of like and I always I
pride myself on I've been a fan of the
show since the very beginning and I have
always hated Tom Sandoval I have known
which I've always hated him and
especially in recent years he doesn't
even do a good job of hiding how
narcissistic oh I hate him is that the
right word narcissistic narcissistic he
is how he's so obsessed and in love with
himself how he's so deeply unwell and
now everyone's seeing what I've been
seeing for years and so I just feel I
feel Vindicated in a sense
I just hate him I always have and I this
wasn't like a big surprise to me the
surprise part was obviously and the
worst part was the Raquel Raquel because
she's from their friends I think that
like I don't know I commented on oh when
the interview came out I commented on
something and then people started trying
to comment down I was like I'm not doing
that
um and people were just like well they
clearly had a messed up relationship and
so I'm like I don't care that doesn't
make anything also a very like
anti-cheater person too I actually think
the whole thing is messed up but like
other than that I think the Friendship
thing is messed up I think she's a very
Raquel Rachel is a very insecure gal
that really really craves attention and
needs it I also think from being in
probably a pretty traumatizing relation
relationship with James where like I do
I can't help a cracker but everything he
says I know hilarious he's so
problematic but he's so funny I know I
couldn't I could not imagine being a
relationship no I mean when she told the
story about him calling her mom fat wait
when was that when she was talking about
like two episodes ago about like they
went to Palm Springs like with her
parents like when they were engaged and
this is what really caused him to break
up he was just going off saying so mean
he was like your dad your dad is so
miserable because he's married to your
fat mom yeah he has no he's horrible
he's crazy and also like I'm sorry like
I actually think she's like cute but
like yeah
I just have never seen someone sit there
and just listen to all this without
being able to say one thing or just be
like shut up no lessons
that fifth episode was weird because
like James and Ali are like kind of
joining this like Outsider crew of Katie
Christina Kelly and Lala like they went
they left Hibachi and went to dinner
with them and it's just [__] weird no
but I do I do get that one him and Lala
used to be best friends so they have
like this connection and I do
maybe Katie
and him they share that frustration I
feel like it's the comfort of like yes
he can't really say how upset he is yeah
even though he's clearly acting that way
because he has a girlfriend next to him
where Katie can be like this is so
upsetting to me so I feel like he feels
Comfort comfortable like with them
especially in the wedding I don't think
that that's the weirdest thing that
they're like in this little crew I think
what is Lala is that what you're gonna
say I love Lala so it's hard like for
years have been Lala apologist but like
it's really hard to kind of defend quite
literally anything she's done this
season because she's been abhorrent and
if we didn't know what we know about
Raquel like I would be so team Raquel
but of course you know the affair
complicates things but I just thought
she was being like kind of a bad friend
to Sheena like not going to the
rehearsal dinner literally the white
party she didn't even show up to and
when Sheena wanted to talk to her about
it she wouldn't even acknowledge it and
she was on my trip inside saying you
know I wasn't a bridesmaid I paid for my
room this is a vacation for me and like
I get it and it is a vacation but like
it's her [__] wedding All I'm gonna
say is I would be way I would be have a
very different reaction than Gina did
yeah yeah I thought China was so chill
and like people came to my hotel yeah my
wedding okay but now I can see like I
hung out with like my enemy Katie I I
just feel bad I like I really like lala
and I just don't want to talk to that no
I know but like like I know a part of
being a host of the toast is like you
have to have those uncomfortable
conversations for me okay well I did I
just said that I would have reacted
differently and I would have been like
pissed off but that's me like if you're
coming to my hotel like where of course
I'm sorry like it's literally where I'm
getting my wedding I'm having my wedding
and you wouldn't be here if I wasn't
having a wedding this weekend and so
like you can't say you're just on
vacation like you should be out of every
possible event or please leave and
Sheena like kind of being chill about it
made me have like a lot of respect for
her
um and then I'm shocked for this show
later on in the night when she shared
with everyone that her and Brock have
actually been married for a year and
they were just like so happy and like
summer they have a baby together
so cute beautiful girl I was like you
know what this kind of makes sense why
shida's not being like a bridezilla like
this wedding is like a formality it's
just for fun right it doesn't really
mean anything in like a spiritual sense
when the veil was flowing in the wind I
would have been like yeah and she was
just like it's okay like she clearly did
some sort of something before that to
just Zen her hours she was like I'm not
gonna bug at this wedding yeah she makes
her more calm of a person and she's much
older than she was at her first wedding
her first wedding she had her first
wedding was me at my wedding like that's
the energy I was giving crazy ass
[__] [__] energy that's how I was
acting yeah um so what do you think
about Schwartz and Raquel
do you think like it was so crazy I
really don't blame Raquel in any sense
like Katie has been horrible to her this
bullied her like why would Raquel
doesn't really owe Katie anything Tom is
completely out Tom is in the wrong yeah
Thomas and then going up like Tom I
would have been James in that situation
don't touch my leg and don't try and
talk to my current girlfriend I actually
he was not wrong at all I know but also
like yeah Tom I've always liked that
shorts but he gives this innocent thing
where he's like what you can't be mad at
me and like trying to be Joker like one
I also think Katie you don't know behind
the scenes what their conversations have
been it probably was like a really big
deal to like choose to end a marriage
but there's allowed to be jealousy there
and also like don't get with my friends
no not even my friends because that's
even that's not what she said she's like
just don't like get in the group and I
don't I don't feel like that's an
unreasonable thing for us either I
totally would be feeling the way she did
and I would have been like shorts get
away yeah and um that was also wrong to
James Raquel I don't think really owes
anything but Raquel's crazy she also
doesn't owe James anything like he was
horrible right she's just kind of like a
free agent and like didn't she break up
with James I don't know we don't really
know how that I don't know who broke up
with who but like she is still very much
like the hurt party he has a new
girlfriend he was horrible to her he
called her mom fat like I feel like I
feel like she really doesn't owe him
anything
there was something else you just asked
Schwartz
um
you said you like him as a person
yeah wait no I'm missing something
oh what I was confused about and that's
why I was texting my mom my sister I
said I'm like I'm a little confused here
because you guys said to me that in like
two episodes ago
um that Tom
Sandoval and Raquel started already
having their fling and then they were
like oh no no no and then I was like
okay that would make more sense because
why would she kiss Schwartz but now
listening to that interview they did
start in Sandoval's eyes before the
wedding they had a connection and they
kissed but I'm thinking that maybe in
Raquel's eyes it wasn't any sort of
connection or a big deal because like
she was like I'm into Tom Schwartz and
then maybe after he got rich Sandoval
got really jealous remember him standing
over the table last night like being
like
yeah
you guys kiss and Ariana's like sit down
yeah I just like he like really was
jealous and now I get it more and he
probably was like like now I want to
like be a thing with her so no one gets
with her the timeline really is
confusing it's really confusing I didn't
get it to now I get it I didn't even get
it from the show last night I was still
confused but then when I watched how
he's interviewing now I understand I
think we'll probably get like a very
clear and concise timeline at The
Reunion yeah but I really can't wait
till the end of May for that wait I'm so
excited I'm so excited we should
literally have a viewing party it's
gonna be the biggest I would love event
like a Super Bowl like yeah it's gonna
be the biggest event of the season I
want to buy a commercial for the toast
while it's airing like I think it'll be
literally the most tuned into
things also I think this is a fun thing
to just be discussing on social media
because usually I am like you're one
that you'll just be like oh my God this
person's like sucks even if you like
know who they are and like you've met a
lot of these people where like I get too
nervous to do that but the only time I
ever started doing that was last year
with Love is Blind so I started doing it
a little more now and this is the first
time I feel like I can do that because
everyone's on one side if you're
somewhat on Raquel's side you are
delusional but I don't think there's
anyone I know so it's like you could say
whatever you want because we're all in a
team together right everyone's like team
Ariana team Ariana it's like of course
team what else yeah yeah
um so let's accept Howie maybe it was
sweet I actually really thought sheena's
wedding was beautiful and I'm really
happy for Natalie was nice and I really
like Brock and I definitely got a little
teared up especially when summer was
walking down the aisle it was sweet
she's so cute and I'm like very picky on
like cute babies and like I think she's
the cutest wait also in this premiere
for next week the preview Katie's
talking about how she's dating someone
who's 25 and she brings this guy to the
um bar and he like literally looks 11.
like he looks like he weighs like 60
pounds I was shook I'm like but then I
feel like any maybe you want to get the
furthest away from what you're like so
true I don't know I've never been
married and I've never like needed to
like turn right like um a lot of people
end up like hooking up with people that
is not their typer that's so true that
is so true I'm interested to see like
more about him you know I'm very much
looking forward to that whole thing
because I was shook when I saw him I was
like wait what
like and he said he was young and I
realized he was in Middle School
um well that's our show Remy thank you
so much for being here I love you guys
be sure to follow Remy everywhere Tick
Tock Instagram at Remy J Bader just Remy
Bader wait that's Mike okay it's ready
Joe oh no no everything is at Remy Bader
okay sorry I didn't mean to confuse
everyone ever made her
um you're the best thank you for being
here love you thank you guys so much for
listening to the testimony Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to show everybody Friday
on YouTube if you're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast
box all the places podcast find us the
toasty five star review that are we
doing stunning and wickedly talented we
are have an amazing Thursday we are in
studio tomorrow for our final episode of
the week with Paige desorbo we'll see
you then bye